I believe it was either probably herself
or she got someone else to do the dirty
work for her again this story for any
journalist would want to take it further
due to pressure from their editors
well Mr Green followed with whose phone
do you think was hacked for this article
I can't be sure my Lord I don't have the
call data
the Barrister then pressed the Duke
saying that's not an answer and asked
the question again
the doctors I'm not sure I can't be sure
Mr Green
well in a more heated exchange Andrew
Green asked Prince Harry if he thought a
journalist hacked the doctor's phone
number adding and we're not in the
Realms of total speculation
no I don't believe so again I'm not the
one who wrote the article you'd have to
ask the one who wrote the article